there are a total of six original dune
novels written by Frank Herbert himself
subsequent books were written by his son
Brian Herbert and Kevin J Anderson now
I've been covering dune on this channel
for a couple of years now and since I've
started covering dune one of the main
things that people have been wanting me
to do this entire time is to rank the
books so guess what you guys are getting
your wish in this video I'll be ranking
the six original Frank Herbert dune
books
in this video I will be ranking frank
herbert's original six doom books we
will save the expanded doom books for
later also keep in mind that these
rankings are based on my own opinion you
may have totally different rankings and
that's fine we will start with number
six before I say what number six is I
should say this I don't believe that any
of these books are bad I think they all
have a purpose but if we are judging
each book on its own then I have to give
the number six spot to Doom Messiah
unlike a lot of people I enjoy doing
Messiah but the fact is this novel works
more as a bridge between dune and
Children of Dune then as a novel on its
own the purpose of Messiah is to
demystify Paul and unday fi Paul in the
readers eye and the book succeeds at
this I think though it doesn't follow
the normal structure of a narrative dune
Messiah gets the number 6 spot because I
feel as though the other five books are
just that much better and expand more on
the dune universe the number 5 spot goes
to chapter house toon chapter house was
originally intended to be the
penultimate novel in the dune saga
things really become desperate in this
book for the Binnie Jesuit sisterhood as
they struggle against the powerful
honored mantras who have unleashed a
devastating assault on the old Empire
chapter house is a great book with a
really memorable ending as well which
people have been debating about for
years number four on my list is heretics
of doom heretics of dune kicks off what
Frank Herbert had intended to be the
final half of the dune saga heretics
introduced us to a new imperial
structure which had formed after the
fall of the worm god emperor in the
later dune books Herbert is exploring
the long view of history this book opens
up nearly 5000 years after the start of
the first novel characters of previous
books have become legends truth has been
distorted by history events that were
witnessed firsthand in previous books
are now myths this book gives us details
about the Bene Gesserit sisterhood that
we had never had before as well and it
was in this novel that I first realized
just how significant the binning Jesuit
powers were they possess the truth
historical records available now that
the worm God had passed their own
ancestral memories stretched back eons
taking the number three spot on my list
is Children of Dune Children of Dune
introduces Leto anga Nima the children
of Paul Atreides who like their aunt
alia had been awakened in the womb this
book also features the return of the
Binney desert lady Jessica mother of
Paul Atreides who featured prominently
in book 1 but was only mentioned in dune
Messiah much of Children of Dune centers
around the mystery of Jack arute - a
mythological siege said to have been
lost to time once it had been home to
the Indu Ali water stealers the most
abominable of all Freeman criminals in
this book Paul's sister Aliyah now in
power struggles with the internal
influence of her maternal grandfather
the Baron Harkonnen Children of Dune is
effectively the end of the first dune
trilogy it ties off most of the hanging
threads of the first two novels and
plants the seeds for the future books
the number 2 spot on my list is Frank
Herbert's classic original book dune I
love doom obviously Frank Herbert's
original book is a science fiction
masterpiece that is influenced countless
novels since I was completely captured
by this universe upon my first reading
of this book it is so impressive how
Frank Herbert builds this gigantic
galaxy in the first book everything just
seems so alive and real dune is an
iconic book what else can I say about it
so it was hard making this list but the
one thing that I was pretty much certain
about was that god emperor of dune would
be number one on my list God Emperor of
dune became my instant favorite when I
first read it I've never quite read
another book like it it is so
unbelievably rich in philosophy and
allegory even more so than the other
novels in this book Frank Herbert shows
us simultaneously how legends and myths
are created and how they evolved over
time and how they are ultimately
destroyed
reading this book feels as though you
are reading records of true events and
the character Leto himself after living
thousands of years on exploring the
multitude of his inner lives is a truly
fascinating and bizarre figure unlike
any other in fiction so there you have
it I have ranked all six books like I
said in the beginning I loved all of
these books even the Brian Herbert ones
and everyone's gonna have a different
opinion but thank you guys so much for
watching and if you liked this video
consider liking and subscribing and if
you really want to support this channel
click the patreon link in the
description